hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in letter 58
Seneca is devoting the bulk of his
discussion to a six fold classification
of being that he says he's getting from
Plato and we have no reason to think
that he's not getting it from some sort
of platonic text or teaching even though
it's difficult to find anything like
this
within the dialogues that we have or the
letters that that we have and think are
genuine you might say well why is Seneca
interested in Plato's classification of
being and he gives two reasons for
caring about this in this letter about
halfway through after he's talked about
you know the different classifications
and how individual material things are
not really beings according to Plato so
he says what do I have to gain from
these fine distinctions of yours nothing
if you ask me but there is actually
something just as the engraver tired
from a long period of close work turns
his eyes away to rest and as we say to
nurture them
so should we sometimes relax our minds
and refresh them with some amusement and
and he says you know this is an
amusement now most of us don't consider
metaphysics to be particularly a
relaxing amusement but Seneca does
because he's been thinking about these
things for quite some time but he also
says that there's another moral that you
can take from these he says I take every
thought no matter how removed from
philosophy and try to extract something
from it and turn it to good use what
could be more distance from the sort of
things I'm interested in than the
matters I explained just now how can the
Platonic ideas make me a better person
he says well maybe we can see this all
those things that minister to our senses
that entice and arouse us are not
accepted by Plato as things that truly
exist thus they are figments and present
an appearance only for a time none of
them are stable or solid and yet we
desire them as if they were to exist
forever and is if we were to possess
them forever
he says you know we can we can use this
as Stoics to consider how fleeting all
of those those material things that
we're seeking after and indeed our
bodies themselves actually are and that
will help us out know early on in the
work he does something that some other
latin writers of his time and before him
have also done which is to apologize for
the inadequacy of the latin language and
he brings up this term Ascencio which is
coming from the word to be sa right
which is a verb and a sense iya is sort
of a substantial of it a way of taking
the verb the B being and making it into
something like a noun a being or being
itself and we don't have to get too
careful about what exactly he means by a
sense yeah this is a term that gets used
by by earlier authors he mentions Cicero
who doesn't actually use it that much
but there's other authors who do in fact
use it and then if you know throughout
the Latin West's later philosophy and
well into the Middle Ages Ascencio
becomes a
very common term to use actually goes
into modern philosophy as well so long
as modern philosophy is being written in
Latin like say what Descartes and Hobbes
did right so this term essentia gets
used and he says that I'm trying to use
this to capture something of the Greek
Lucia which is often translated as
substance it's a term that we see it you
know running throughout Greek philosophy
and again there's a lot of different
ways of understanding what Lucia means
but you know think about it is like the
the bedrock ontologically stuff any any
talks about this he says here we go
there's no way I can express in Latin
the concept that induced me to take our
language to task you'll objector Rome
limitations even more than I do when you
learn that the word I'm incapable of
rendering is just one syllable we're
gonna we're gonna come to that
before that he says how will I render
Asiya for that is a necessary item
nature that comprises the basis of all
things
so I'm asking your permission to use
this word ascend SIA to to render it now
the other term that he brings up is even
wider in scope the Greek tow own and he
says oh man I'm not happy with myself
because I have to render this this
particular you know word which is a noun
the tow means la or or you know it's
sort of a it's a prat is it's something
we use to designate the thing that is
being right the thing that's in the
process of being or whatever we're gonna
we're gonna call it in Latin its quote
asked quote that which and then asked is
so Cicero that Cicero Seneca is not
entirely happy about the translation
here but that the idea is what is what
has being what exists so before he goes
into discussing Plato he just mentions
that Plato has a six-fold way of
understanding this he says let's
consider genus Azure genera
is the proper way talking about it and
species and he says I must state there
is such a thing as a genus and a species
at present we're looking for that
primary genus on which all the remaining
species depend from which arises every
division in which all things are
included so what is the most
encompassing genus the bag that you can
put everything else into so you know
first of all what are you know genus and
species think about individuals got this
tie or this human being in front of you
right or this piece of truck now that is
an individual a particular and it falls
under a certain kind of species so I
fall under the species of human being
this tie fight falls under the species
ties and not the species articles of
clothing or accessories that's a higher
organizational thing a bigger class that
is what here we're calling a genus and
where it gets a little confusing
particularly if you if you think about
you know how we organize animals is that
there it isn't a species genus and then
everything above it all those other
things above it those other classes
those are also genus Azure genera so
we're looking for the one that actually
encompasses the most and and then we can
do this by a process of sort of climbing
to it so we can start with well let's
say human being right as a species
horses of species dog is the species
what's shared between them animate
creature now we have a genus and then we
can say okay some things are living
they're animate some things are not
animate so we can say we have living
things the animals and plants are in
that and then we have rocks and bodies
being added to it and we have this genus
of bodies and then we can say well is
there something higher than body yes
some things are corporeal bodily other
things are incorporeal so we're getting
closer and closer to this this
encompassing genus as
he says the Stoics that which is the
generic genus has nothing above it at
the beginning of all things all others
are subordinate because the Stoics want
a place above this yet another still
more primary genus as well so he's going
to come to that in a bit and that that's
ultimately going to be you know God then
he talks about the real centerpiece of
this letter which is Plato's six fold
division and again I want to remind you
this is not coming from any one of the
Platonic dialogues as far as we can tell
so he says the first things that are is
he says not apprehended by sight or
touch or any sense
it is the thinkable that which is by
genus for example the generic human does
not present itself to the eye but the
specific does such as Cicero and Cato
right animate creature is not seen it is
thought and what one sees are its
species horse and dog
so the genus is themselves have a
certain kind of being they are something
that is and we might say well yeah they
I guess you could say they have being
they're being and then in the way that
they are in our minds or something and
this is something where the ancients are
a bit more willing to say no there's
there's something out there it's not
something you can actually torture or
smell or grab ahold of or see with your
eyes but you can grasp it with your mind
so that's the first one then he talks
about something really interesting
what exceeds and surpasses all other
things right and this is the second of
things that that have being and he says
this is preeminent being he says the
worded poet is used commonly since this
is the name for all of make verses but
among the Greeks it is by now come to
refer only to one when you hear poet you
understand Homer if you're a Thomas
Aquinas you talk about the philosopher
you mean Aristotle right so what is
is being now this is where it gets
really interesting right because for
Plato if we were gonna say well what is
this it's the form of the good or the
form of the beautiful the beautiful as
such the good and such it's not God
because the gods themselves are kind of
lesser than that but from the stoic
perspective
he says obviously this is God since it's
greater and more powerful than anything
else and God is understood as the divine
reason governing the entire universe
that is there even when the universe
burns up in the universal conflagration
and then comes back together so that's
the second class of being then we start
to get some stuff that we recognize a
little bit more closely from Plato the
ideas the what we often call the
Platonic forms but here we want to avoid
the word form because seneca is going to
use it in a different much more
Aristotelian way the ideas the things
that are immortal eternal and unchanging
he talks about them as being models and
that fits the Platonic ideas of them
being para digmole the things that we
model things after and he says that
everything that we see comes into being
everything is shaped in accordance with
them as for what an idea is or what
Plato thinks an idea is listen an idea
is the eternal model of those things
which come naturally into being and then
he says to this I will add some
interpretation so as to make a subject
plainer to you here is receta cos
deviating considerably from Plato he
says okay I want to make a portrait of
you I am as a model for the I have used
a model for the picture from that model
my mind receives a certain configuration
to impart to its work your the idea in
that case and he says here's where it
gets very non platonic the worlds nature
includes countless models of this sort
know that by itself is not non platonic
here's where it actually becomes so
models of human beings of the various
fishes and trees all things that must
come into be
by nature's agency are formed according
to these models now where's the plural
coming in that's that you know if
there's any plurality in these these
models you know where we would have more
than one model of a human being then we
got a problem all right so he doesn't
actually you know discuss that further
because he's interested in these being
things again we grasped just through the
mind then we have the a dose or the form
and this is much more resilient in the
sense that the form is in the thing so
the form of the tie is the structure of
this piece of cloth right and if this
cloth was arranged in a different way it
might be a handkerchief or a blanket or
who knows what else a napkin holder
right if all this stuff that comprises
my body were arranged in slightly
different ways I would not be a human
being I would be medical waste or a
corpse or whatever we're going to talk
about because things wouldn't be lined
up properly right so that has being as
well he says and then the form itself
think about like a statue right when you
impart form to the material of the
statue it's going from being a block of
marble to being a David right or it's
going from being bronze that's you know
now being poured and shaped into being
an archer or whatever else you want it
to be another thing that he talks about
the fifth thing he says things that
exist commonly and in the Latin for this
is qui community door swings and the
examples that he give here it gives here
are kind of interesting he says this
includes everything omnia right all
things people farm animals things you
might say well these are sort of generic
themselves aren't they yes and no you
know he sees a distinction here between
the the generic things and the things
that are spoken or you might say
designated
commonly and then there's things that we
can translate in English as kind of
exists don't really exist but kind of
exist
he says quasi sunt and what are these
sorts of things the void time they they
have being but they don't really have
being but they they are and so you know
how do we describe these now what's been
left out here's where it gets really
interesting well human beings as
individual human beings or really
anything that we can touch smell hear
individual material things he says
everything we see or touch is excluded
by Plato from those things which are on
his view which on his view are in the
strict sense why because they are in
flux and constantly decreasing and
increasing no one of us is the same in
all the age as it was in youth not one
of us is the same in the morning as he
was the day before were in constant
change our bodies are carried away like
rushing streams and then he says this is
what Heraclitus the great pre-socratic
philosopher means when he says we step
into the same river twice and not at all
the name of the river remains the same
the water has passed on and he says this
is more evidence in a river than in a
human being but a current sweeps us
along as well and it's no less Swift so
with a river it's easy to tell that it's
not the same river because it's
constantly in flux and we just assign a
certain name to it but the waters
actually have moved on it's not so easy
with us where our cells are you know
slowly dying and being replaced and
things are changing all of the time and
so you know Seneca is willing to say
that according to Plato those things
don't really exist they appear they
present themselves in a way but what's
presenting itself is constantly changing
this stuff these other six divisions of
toen
of quo tests what has being what
what exists those are the things that
really are and so that's what we should
be more focused on according to Plato
and Seneca himself is willing to say
yeah there's there's something to that
idea we can get something out of this
you